what's up everyone I'm Walter Benes II
act and this is top five I've been
feeling a little nostalgic this week so
I decided to do a video on Pokemon when
I was a kid Pokemon was insanely popular
I know it's still very popular but back
then it was all new to us and I didn't
know one kid who didn't love it it was
beyond a phenomena whether you played
the video games watched the anime
collected the cards or all three Pokemon
was almost a lifestyle with the advent
of the pokemons go laughs last year
people around the world became
enthralled all over again with this
brand and it's proved to have real
staying power in pop culture the
original 151 Pokemon were the ones we
originally fell in love with they were
unique cool epic legendary
however even back then there were a
select few we all hate it whenever we
found one in a newly opened booster pack
or encounter one of these stinkers in
the games we all let out this same
disappointed groan today I wanted to
count down the worst ones the pokemons
that were lackluster then and just lame
now before we go any further I need to
admit I'm pretty rusty with all this
stuff it's been a while with me in
Pokemon so I thought I'd call in an
expert
[Music]
what Walter hey I need your help on a
video it's not Power Rangers I don't
know I'm pretty far out of town right
now where you at the orbit report
satellites they beam us down every
Monday at 5 p.m. right here on the
channel awesome YouTube channel okay
well I guess I'll just do this Pokemon
video by myself I'm down let's do this
these are the top five worst original
Pokemon number five mr. mime
who doesn't love mines called barrier
tin Japan mr. mime is a psychic
fairy-type pokémon that evolves from
mime jr and whose design is unnerving ly
based on a mine clown combination in the
anime Ash's mother had a mr. mime as her
companion Pokemon it helped her around
the house and was basically a glorified
maid it can create actual walls by
stopping molecules in the air but if you
try to interrupt it mr. mime will slap
you like a bitch mr. mime is one of the
weirdest looking Pokemon of Gen one and
that is saying something the cute factor
can only go so far with this thing if
you have any kind of fear of clowns mr.
mime might be your worst nightmare just
look at its innocent eyes don't trust
them at any moment mr. mime can trap you
in a box until you suffocate it can
catch you with an invisible rope and
force you to be its Pokemon fighting
other humans in a secret game of death
until their species is ready to take
over the world I got my eye on you mr.
mime you don't fool me okay man we get
number four at eye kikuna and Metapod
ever see a cocoon hanging from a tree
and think I bet that thing kicks ass
kikuna is a bug poison type Pokemon that
evolves from wheedle and later evolves
into Beedrill Metapod is a bug type
pokemon that evolves from Caterpie and
evolves into Butterfree this in-between
stage is a bit boring though it's
literally just a cocoon they can't move
much and only defend themselves by using
harden if an enemy gets close enough to
one kikuna may try and sting it by using
its poisonous Barb's other than that
they just kind of hang out and wait to
become a bead roll or a Butterfree well
mr. mime can be kind of scary kikuna and
Metapod are just lame why are their
evolutions from wheedle and Caterpie
just an awkward middle point until they
get to their third form the whole point
of the evolution of Pokemon is to
transform into something else
kikuna and Metapod literally just
transform in
you transformative States I know they're
based on real animals that do this but
come on
couldn't they form the cocoon for a very
short amount of time before evolving
into their final stages hey kids you
like blast toys yeah Moltres too bad
here's a cocoon have fun number three
jinx
yeah look this is just an extremely
uncomfortable Pokemon jinx is an ice
psychic-type pokémon that evolves from
Smoochum it constantly dances and moves
its hips people subliminally move along
with it without noticing and it puts its
enemies to sleep by using its signature
move lovely kiss jinkx is just
disturbing on so many different levels
so many levels you want to take this one
fine I'm sure it wasn't intended this
way but jinxes design can come off a bit
racially insensitive in this country and
no changing its skin color to purple has
not helped this Pokemon and mr. Popo
from Dragonball Z are in a class of
their own by the way changing his skin
colour to blue was extra dumb as well at
least in DBZ mr. Popo is a somewhat
useful character besides his appearance
jinx is just bizarre as hell it seduces
its opponents by rhythmically wiggling
its hips and finishes them off by
kissing them it's often stated that
jinxes cries are very similar to humans
but they haven't been able to decipher
what they mean instead it seems to
mainly communicate by dancing which
makes this thing even stranger I get the
heebie-jeebies from this Pokemon just
keep it away from me moving on number
two Magikarp weak pathetic worthless
these are all words that are commonly
and accurately used to describe Magikarp
Magikarp is a water type Pokemon that
evolves into Gyarados it's basically a
running joke in the Pokemon world while
magikarps distant ancestors were said to
be somewhat stronger the modern version
is basically useless it uses splash a
move that has absolutely no effect on
its opponent in fact it will randomly
splash out of the water and get
routinely consumed by its predators it's
a true waste of life until it evolves
into the badass Gyarados everyone knows
it Magikarp is pretty much the worst
positives for Magikarp are few and far
between it has a very strong immune
system which means it can survive in
highly polluted waters
if this Pokemon lives long enough it's
said that it can leap high enough out of
the water to scale mountains other than
that the only real reason we're keeping
it off the number one spot is because it
evolves into a giant water dragon
Gyarados is one of the coolest pokemon
out there and without Magikarp we
wouldn't have it at all but yeah magic
carpets elf is useless in battle your
only hope is to one day of all of us
until then good luck with that
devastating splash attack four down one
to go and the number one worst original
Pokemon is Goldeen
are you sure Goldeen is worse than
Magikarp
oh I'm sure huh Goldeen is a water type
Pokemon that evolves into seeking while
beautiful to the eye it's known to be
very temperamental and somewhat
dangerous because of its horn
Goldeen will often use it when thinking
it's being threatened or when being held
in some sort of aquarium to escape but
there's one big reason why this stupid
Pokemon takes the top spot on my list
it's been ruining Super Smash Brothers
matches for my entire life just when I
thought I'd have an advantage at a
difficult match just when I thought I'd
gain the upper hand by grabbing a
pokeball I'd throw it open it illegally
the trolling Goldeen inflicts in the
Smash Brothers games is disgraceful I
hate this smartass fish hate it as a
regular pokemon gold Ian's pretty weak
but not the weakest why was it chosen to
sorrell these matches questions about
and don't tell me just to not the items
it turn out pokeballs
I'm sorry I like to have fun in these
games sometimes the fun would be better
if this grating goldfish would stop
showing up at the worst moments we all
love Pokemon of course these five are
but a small minority to the awesome
creatures that were introduced to us in
the original 151 even if we didn't like
some of them we still tried to catch
them all we want to hear what you guys
think what's your least favorite
original Pokemon what do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know you can find me on
channel awesomes newest show orbit
report right here on Mondays
you can also find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse or Instagram at a truce for
more content subscribe to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome alter
like my new Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome Walter B and follow along
on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what may be covered in the future
well see ya beam me up
[Applause]
by
[Music]
you